bonjour et ados vj merci à d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france on l'a vu
les images sont impressionnantes elles
font froid dans le dos on imagine le
peuple libanais sous choc ce matin
racontez-nous comment vous vous avez
vécu c'est terrible explosion hier en
fin de journée
elle sonne elle ment je n'étais pas à
vélo j'étais en demandez vous à
l'extérieur
j'étais dans un ascenseur d'ailleurs et
on l'a senti à une petite soupe ou sans
l'ascenseur rien de très inquiétant
c'est après que on nous a dit ce qu'ils
avaient eu et je n'ai réalisé que très
progressivement parce que dans les
premières annonces
on avait d'abord dit qu'il y avait eu
une explosion à la maison du futur c'est
à dire quelqu'un contre monsieur a
vieilli et puis après à la télévision
toujours que c'était un dépôt de deux
feux d'artifice et et ensuite on a dit
non il ya eu une explosion qui étaient
d'une nature différente mais c'est en
revenant vers beyrouth que j'ai réalisé
progressivement l'anc lors de lors de la
destruction
si ces impôts kelly petit coach mais je
n'ai jamais vu ça justement on a vu
aussi à des scènes d'apocalypse dans les
hôpitaux notamment à l'hôpital
saint-georges tout près d'achraf signé
trois hôpitaux de campagne vont être
installés pour désengorger les hôpitaux
de la capitale saturée il ya aussi le co
vide tout ça est un contexte difficile
pour le liban pensez vous que les
hôpitaux vont parvenir à gérer l'afflux
des blessés dans les prochains jours je
pense que les blessés sont déjà dans les
hôpitaux je pense qu'effectivement
locaux vides bat énormément compliquer
les choses à mon avis les la
distanciation va être totalement
impossible parce qu'il va falloir c'est
essayer toutes là la capitale qui est
qui est dévasté je crois qu'il ya qui
est très peu d'appartements qui sont
encore en état
donc je pense que après là c'est cette
catastrophe il va y avoir ensuite
laquelle 500 qui va être le duo kobe
donc comment est-ce que les les hôpitaux
vont gérer tout ça d'autant plus qu'un
certain nombre
ont été dévastés je ne saurais pas vous
dire mais je pense que le peuple
libanais avec l'aide de ses amis dans le
monde entier validé à se tirer d'un fake
comment se sont révélés les libanais ce
matin vous autour de vous quelle est
l'atmosphère qu'il ya dans la vie à
présent je crois en l'état de chant
hills avant le lever d'être également
progressif c'est à dire que c'est petit
à petit que les jambons vont réaliser
que le feu dans la maison sont au delà
de ce que ce qu'ils peuvent imaginer que
leur bureau certains n'existent plus que
lafleur notre travail et les compromis
donc donc je crois que le relèvement
progressif
ils se sont endormis avec une certaine
un temps sur certaines l'un dans un état
d'abattement disons et je crois que
petit à petit vont se réveiller à la
je crois qu'on a un problème technique
avec ryad au b j alors on passe en
france on vous à vous nous entendez ryad
au bep j on a eu un petit problème
technique
oui vous m'entendez très bien le nitrate
d'ammonium serait désigné comme étant à
l'origine des explosions l'enquète elle
est toujours en cours ce matériau il a
été laissé dans un entrepôt près du port
comment l expliquer ce que c'est une
négligence du gouvernement
je n'ai aucune idée je pense que c'est
essentiellement une exigence j'ai
entendu la déclaration du du premier
ministre je vois sur vos images le silo
de blé qui a été pulvérisée
je pense que ce n'est pas simplement du
nitrate d'ammonium parce que le labour
ciel de blé clé aussi de très fortes
explosions
donc je pense que c'est c'est une série
de négligences et puis et puis quand
vous avez une série de négligences
c'est un fait de dieu comment la classe
politique va faire face à cet événement
les libanais ont déjà perdu espoir alors
gouvernement est ce que c'est le bon
moment pour rebondir finalement alors
cela la classe politique est
décrédibilisé est-ce que ils vont
arriver à rebondir chez certains si
jamais il montre du collage et pas
simplement jeter la faute les uns sur
les autres je crois que ces deux
collèges dont nous avons besoin
aujourd'hui et de la clairvoyance et
puis aussi de nouvelles cures on n'est
plus temps de dire non on a en tête amis
ils sont plus amis que d'autres amis ou
un ou une telle ennemis sont mois et
demi que d'autres les ennemis je crois
que il faut il faut ouvrir les bras tout
le monde et il faut accepter l'aide de
tout le monde dernière question à rien
de veigy ces événements les
interviennent à un moment où le pays
s'enfonce dans une crise économique
sociale et politique sans précédent
le liban avec des épreuves très
difficiles ces dernières décennies
comment est-ce que le pays peut-il se
relever de cette catastrophe
je pense que c'est peut-être l'occasion
de signer davantage de retrouver un
petit peu non les valeurs humaines je
crois que le liban a été un pays surtout
de joie de grippe peut-être que la
douleur vous signez là là où la joie n'a
pas plu nous unit merci à rien de région
va finir sur ces mots je rappelle que
vous êtes président directeur général de
la banque bemo vivant